I'm excited for madtv's return because I
think it's time for another edgy sketch
comedy show I'm super pumped for MADtv
to come back because finally I get to
show the world how great I look and blue
sweaters what what I'm excited about
madtv's return because one I get to be
on TV
suck at middle school [ __ ] know I'm
so excited for MADtv to return one cuz
I'm on it and two my dad could stop
complaining about me not going to law
school you son of a [ __ ] I did it I'm
excited because I feel that there's
always room for more sketch comedy and
MADtv was the thing that everybody kind
of grew up with it's still vibrant being
a part of such an iconic show is a dream
come true
because I grew up on MADtv I'm excited
for madtv's return because I'm gonna be
in it if you want to get to know me you
have to know that ariana grande is one
of my favorite artists well to get to
know who I am
maybe I should share a little bit of
what I do I do a lot of impressions for
example Don Trump we're gonna build
America a great wall a really big wall
that's gonna knock out all the light and
we're just gonna become a shadow State
it's gonna be great I would probably be
pegged as nicest most intense class
clown
I would probably be voted like easiest
to work with or something taking up
water or what man
well the CW network is perfect for MADtv
because they've got the flash and as we
know MADtv is very fast and they've got
arrow 19 view right on target and
they've got a crazy ex-girlfriend and of
course TV is crazy the CW is the perfect
Network for Mad TV because it's young
it's fun it's sexy like everyone on the
cast CW is a perfect place for Mad TV
because when I think a comedy I think of
vampires now what is uh is that really